[Musique]
aujourd'hui 14 mars icpc vraiment
quelque chose d'important sur le plateau
de saclay un ensemble d'acteurs de la
recherche
il souhaite la recherche amont et la
roja c'est plus appliquée dans le
domaine du numérique ont décidé de se
réunir et de porter ensemble un projet
en commun
ce projet il s'appelle digitec
l'objectif c'est que le numérique sur le
plateau de saclay soit vraiment un axe
très fort un axe visible un axe
mobilisateur et fédérateur
c'est la raison pour laquelle le cea
list l'inria l'ird et systémique
l'institut télécom le pôle de
compétitivité systematic paris région
ont décidé ensemble de porter un projet
en commun
ce projet en commun c'est apprendre à un
projet de rosemary scientifiques et
techniques et partage et qui a pour
objectif d'aider les entreprises
nationales mais aussi francilienne dans
leurs développements technologiques
numériques
ce projet va s'incarner dans un bâtiment
qui s'appellera digitec et qui va réunir
l'ensemble de ses acteurs l'annoncé a
été faite ce matin même parfaite hendry
vice président de la région ile de
france en charge de la recherche
elle a aussi inauguré ce matin même à
design center sur le site de nano innov
là où dix y va se construire
sitech c'est donc à la fois un pôle
numérique d'activité à part est sacrée
mais c'est aussi un centre d'innovation
tirée par les usages et par le design ce
sont deux axes importants
[Musique]
personnalisés ils vont caractériser de
projets de stijl aujourd'hui je passe
deux événements importants
le premier porté par le sinistre c'est
le tec des boulistes jeté du liste c'est
quoi ce sont toutes les deux
démonstrateurs technologiques toutes les
capacités technologiques de l'institut
de recherche du cea
ils sont mis en visibilité sont mis en
avant deuxième événement la journée
future and system x est l'événement
annuel de liberté systèmes ips qui vise
à mettre en avant les différents travaux
collaboratifs peut dire tu es a permis
de développer
c'est ainsi qu'aujourd'hui plus d'un
millier de personnes notamment et
principalement industrielle sont
présentes aujourd'hui donc c'est des
vrais ce lancement du projet 10 tête
[Musique]